it's finally time for some competition
Nvidia has had a few month head start
with their 4080 and 4090 allowing them
to basically charge whatever they want
but now it's time for AMD the new Radeon
7900 XT and XTX they aim to undercut the
pricing of nvidia's heavyweight gpus
while still offering Enthusiast
performance at 4K and in a smaller and
more digestible package for the consumer
today we'll be putting the top of the
stack RX 7900 XTX priced at a thousand
dollars against the RTX 4080 and the
4090 and on paper it's looking pretty
good so far in typical AMD fashion we
get more video memory than what Nvidia
has to offer and in this case faster
memory as well and although it's an
apples to oranges comparison 96 compute
units is the most that AMD has ever
stacked onto a GPU now a quick look at
the test bench here we've got a ryzen
5800 X 3D and 36 gigabytes of 3600
megahertz memory and a beefy power
supply as well I will note that as usual
I've tested with smart Access Memory AK
resizable bar disabled for these tests
and that gives us a more even comparison
between these gpus so the performance
that you're about to see is completely
stock out of the box performance with
fresh driver installs and that's it
without further Ado let's see how fast
this thing actually is and against the
RTX 4080 in Modern Warfare 2 the new
7900 XTX gives Nvidia an absolute
beating at 1440p the AMD card is 23
faster on average here while being 200
cheaper even when we add the 4090 into
the picture a 600 more expensive GPU the
7900 XTX is keeping up extremely well so
far things are looking pretty good for
the AMD card but the games aren't always
this impressive in Forza Horizon at 4K
completely maxed out the 4080 and the
new 7900 XTX are basically equal at the
end of The Benchmark run here both
average around 134 FPS but the new AMD
card does that while costing 200 less
and that's really the match up here
right 4080 versus 7900 XTX if you were
expecting the new AMD Flash ship to beat
nvidia's 1490 while costing 600 less
unfortunately that just isn't happening
here in God of War again at 4K the 4080
and 7900 XTX are basically tied in
performance with the 4090 being about 40
faster than both of them again though
factoring value into the equation the
new AMD Flagship is putting up extremely
confident performance then in Red Dead
Redemption 2 4K High settings 4080 and
7900 XTX are virtually tied again
looking at them side by side but at the
end of The Benchmark run the AMD card is
actually eight percent faster now I
think before these results many would
expect close to 40 90 performance with
the XTX but evidently the 4090 is in a
completely different league and as it
should be because it is 600 more
expensive so let's take a look at the
average then across 12 games at 4K
between the 4080 and the 7900 XTX as you
can see it's a tough battle AMD Winsome
and video wins some others for the most
part though you're getting pretty
similar performance now if we convert
this graph 2 percentages we can see
what's happening here a little bit
clearer and yeah the 4080 and 7900 XTX
they're virtually equal while the 4080
averaged 124 FPS across 12 games at 4K
the new AMD GPU managed 123.4 so
basically it's the same performance
being 200 cheaper though that of course
makes it the better pick over the 4080.
essentially you're paying less for the
same performance on average I think 40
90 owners though are feeling pretty
comfortable and again it's a much more
expensive GPU so it should be much much
faster and across the same 12 games it
is on average I found the 4090 to be 37
faster than amd's new flagship and
although the cost per frame is better
than the 4080 the 7900 XTX is the better
value option especially when you take a
look at Modern Warfare 2 or war zone 2
for that matter which is the most
popular game in this graph at the moment
the 7900 XTX is looking pretty damn good
for the money so 7900 XTX versus 4080
it's looking like a pretty clean sweep
but there's something else that we
should factor into the equation here and
that's power how much power these gpus
are chugging back while spinning out all
of these frames is really important to
consider and I see you guys in the
comments this is something that people
are really beginning to care about by
now we've seen these massive new cooler
designs from Nvidia to deal with all of
the heat output as well as the stories
of the new 16-pin adapter melting AMD on
the other hand the new XTX is much much
smaller and only uses two eight pin
connectors but this is where things get
really interesting here we're looking at
total system power draw from the wall
but since we've used the same test bench
for both gpus that's where the
differences are coming from White is the
4080 and orange is the new 7900 XTX and
in dumateral at 4K it's actually the AMD
GPU that pulls about 40 Watts more than
we have God of War also at 4K
differences are a little bit closer here
but still the AMD GPU surprisingly pulls
more power but then we take a look at
OverWatch 2 at 1440p the 4080 sips power
in this title as it should but the AMD
card is flat on the gas pulling 150
watts more for anomalies like this you
obviously go back and test multiple
times which I did but I kept getting the
same results probably more concerning
though is what happens when you're just
idling on the desktop they're the AMD
card again just randomly pulls so much
power for no reason at all here it chugs
back an extra 80 Watts over the 4080
while it does nothing and looking at
some of the monitoring software we can
see that it pulls close to 100 Watts
again this is complete idle desktop use
even after a fresh restart hopefully
it's something that AMD can fix quickly
because it's simply unacceptable
somewhere else where the 4080 has an
advantage though is when it comes to Ray
tracing performance here we're looking
at control at 4K with Ray tracing crank
to the max but without any upscaling
techniques like dlss or FSR essentially
what we're looking at here is how much
of an impact retracing has on these gpus
and you can see it has less of an impact
when we switch it on for the 4080. now
the 4080 is the faster GPU in this title
without retracing but the margin grows
from about 8 to around 30 percent when
we turn Ray tracing on so it's basically
a sweep for the 4080 if you like playing
with Ray tracing on I mean here in Doom
Eternal with 4K and RT on the margin is
almost 40 for the RTX 4080 over the new
7900 XTX which does lead to a pretty
massive frame rate difference long story
short the ray tracing capabilities of
the 4080 are significantly ahead of the
7900 XTX while in non-retraced games the
two are practically even switching Ray
tracing on does make the 4080 look like
the 200 more expensive GPU that it
actually is but an area where AMD has
caught up to Nvidia surprisingly his
video encoding so if you do a bit of
streaming and you're looking for the
best quality possible the matchup is
actually pretty close which is
surprising because historically this is
where Nvidia has led undefeatedly both
the new AMD and Nvidia gpus feature av1
encoding support which gives a huge
boost to visual quality and playing them
side by side here I mean it's actually
impossible to tell the difference the
rtx40 here is on the left and the 7900
XTX is on the right and as far as stream
quality goes they're both incredibly
good both of them look better than 99 of
twitch streams that you'll see today and
that's thanks to the new av1 support in
fact even pausing some frames here and
comparing them side by side sometimes
Nvidia looks better but sometimes AMD
looks better it really just depends on
what frame you're looking at I was
actually convinced that Nvidia would
still be ahead here despite AMD adding
av1 support but that's actually not the
case amd's ev1 encoding looks virtually
identical to nvidias maybe Nvidia looked
slightly better over more comparisons
but it's so damn close especially if
you're playing in real time but until
OBS actually add support for ev1 for
streaming which supposedly is late this
year or early next year you'll be stuck
with h.264 encoding on either GPU and
that's where there really is a massive
difference amd's h.264 encoding there's
no nice way to say it it's basically
trash now for whatever reason it's just
a blurry mess compared to what nvidia's
looks like there's no need to zoom in
here because the difference is pretty
clear the performance overhead while
streaming on a 4080 or a 7900 XTX though
is about even which is surprising
because the 4080 has two video encoded
chips whereas the AMD card only has one
so I'm not sure if OBS is fully taking
advantage of the two chips that the 4080
actually has before that's worth both
see pretty much the same minimal
difference while streaming and gaming at
the same time video editing in DaVinci
Resolve is also pretty good on the 7900
XTX and specifically looking at export
speeds here although there's no ev1
support for AMD it still manages to beat
the 4080 while using h.265 in the end
it's about six percent faster though I
also checked the actual rendered videos
and kind of just examined the quality of
the two and you know the differences
were pretty minuscule to say the least
to the untrained eye both look identical
and even when looking at the waveforms
and the histograms between the two which
shows you the objective color data there
was almost no difference to speak of
there are some slight differences when
it comes to the saturation and the Hue
but that's mostly a difference between
av1 and h.3 65 rather than AMD and
Nvidia I will say though Nvidia is still
the undoubted pick for 3D professionals
blender showed the 7900 XTX to be about
on par with a 3080 which doesn't look
good at all I'll also mention that some
renderers just simply won't accept an
AMD GPU so for 3D work Nvidia is still
the most sensible pick now quick note on
thermals after 40 minutes in firm Mark
the 7900 XTX settled in at 68 degrees
and 350 Watts with the room ambient at
23. Pretty good overall but with that
much heat load you'll definitely need a
well ventilated case I know I've shown
previously how you can cram this thing
into some pretty small cases but you'll
100 want to give this thing some active
calling cramming it into a Sentry 2.0 or
at the bottom of an end case M1 for
example I don't know if that's the best
idea for a two and a half slot cooler
though on an Open Bench it's pretty damn
good
all right so closing thoughts if AMD can
fix the weird power consumption on this
card when at idle and at 1440p then it's
a decent alternative over the RTX 4080.
that's also if you don't care about
retracing performance 3D work and dlss
frame generation on the 40 series and if
you're more focused on is getting as
much value out of your frame rates as
possible because yeah roughly equal
rasterization performance at 200 cheaper
that's a pretty good deal again though
the aggressive power consumption needs
to absolutely be fixed at idle and for
1440p gaming especially when AMD present
themselves as the more power efficient
alternative it's just really weird to
see that but I'd love to know what you
guys think down below as always a huge
thanks for watching and I'll see you all
in the next one